ma perchè non fai un blog con i tuoi
genitori
non ho mai pensato di fare una roba del
genere perché perché non so che cosa
minchia possa uscir fuori però vabbè
prova da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti o che
sono video sono fa vj due parmigiani a
brown era proprio e tu sei mamma mamma
mamma j pari la fantasia in famiglia è
imbarazzante questa è veramente
imbarazzante non ho seriamente non
pensare a me è perfetto bravo molto
bravo
ciao ragazzi come sei tori di partire
con la fama della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da laura che ha
fatto sto disegni dal tratto si chiama
come te l'ha rifatta tour stata lei
detto questo se possiamo passare alle
news veramente una cosa stranissima tu
fai tanto quei paghino
si si taglia tutte queste scene ricche e
non ti preoccupare comunque ragazzi per
quanto riguarda le news domani che
domenica uscirà allo speciale l'ultimo
speciale 2 milioni di iscritti che ci ho
messo una vita fa tanto lo sapete qual è
siccome mancano tipo 19 20 giorni più o
meno all'uscita del gene therapy del
film durante le riprese del film ho
fatto una cosa che mi sono ispirato
patimenti all'attore dell'hobby perché
sarebbe martin freeman che durante le
riprese ha fatto faceva delle scene col
dito medio ma mandava affanculo
riguardava la telecamera durante le
riprese io che sono un ragazzo serio
vero che sono un ragazzo stesso un
ragazzo serio ho fatto la stessa
identica cosa dovete anche nei prossimi
blog perché faccio una specie di mini
serie su sta cosa direi che possiamo
partire con i primi pezzi
[Musica]
lui
sì esattamente questa cosa sta
diventando più imbarazzanti di quanto
pensassimo dai ragazzi siccome non ci
sono i patti quindi non possiamo farlo
ska anche perché fare lo scarta gb pac
in tre un po un casino proviamo a fare
una sfida qualche mese fa circa adesso
non mi ricordo erano uscite le caramelle
e quali rischi al gusto dove tutti
facciamo nelle challenge adesso che
siamo in gruppo facciamo una roba un po
carina vi va di fare queste cose
stai proprio la voglia che ti sta
proprio a salendo iole chi era nelle
loro zio ho preso un pò tante
praticamente funziona st cross che noi
ci dobbiamo mangiare una caramella a
testa è praticamente una è buona no
spetta sono tutte buone e una fa schifo
quella che fa schifo vara cioè se la
becca una di noi e proprio a random
proviamo a farlo ma spenderci
sull'istruzione allora se ci sono
l'aspetto vedo il pacchetto che
arrivarono subito capito ma seppe che
quella che non è buona dovevi dire no ti
si vede in faccia di merda
noi dobbiamo girare questa roba qua
nesta inizio facciamo che inizio io una
di queste qui sono tutte buone tranne
una che fa schifo dai partiamo ci siete
lui è uscito blu
in teoria i sapori son due sapone grasso
e quello brutto e quello buona e
mirtillo di montagna una di queste qua
ci fa vomitare voi prendete nessuna io
prendo l'altra ok
adesso ci dobbiamo mangiare al mio tre
tutti insieme quella che fa più schifo e
vabbè ma va benissimo davvero tanto ci
siamo alla prima andata brava mamma 6 a
1 az e vincendo tua vince chi fa più
schifo
certo stavolta fa da toccate vai
complimenti e bravissimo verde succo di
pera è quello buono quello che fa schifo
è apple e non è breve joe peggio e pesce
marcio e allora quando facciamo le cose
hanno assaggiato il pesce marcio per
sapere come come era se mi becco di
loculario bondi toast a bologna e monica
si aspetta aspetta quanti traggono via
papa teschi ragazzi culo ma niente che
la tua mamma soldi ai viola è questa
ancora meglio tra l'altro quella buona e
torta di lamponi me la schifosa non so
come fanno a sapere se i sapori qui però
c'è scritto c'è scritto letame fresco
6 via niente sono 2 2 a 1
ancora un cazzo la prossima volta
facciamo un raduno facciamo tutti
insieme stavano bacio è bellissimo anno
l'ho né del nonno
ma cosa vuol dire che ha un gusto
diverso dal pallone della nonna ad
esempio quello buona e melone giallo
però in a ho capito come fanno a sapere
il gusto del pannolone del no vale
dall'odore non si sente siete così via
che schifo la mia fa schifo
applico si sa il pannolone del nonno
voglio saperne una curiosità proprio
illusori c'è quando due assaggiata hai
detto il cazzo questo punto pannone bere
fammi bene non vuoi bene poi verrà il
piccio del nonno land 220 e sa
miracolato rosa è cimice
si no certo si sono mangiati le cinque e
bear grylls che ha fatto studio e
l'altra e tutti i frutti
c'è un'altra sa di tuttifrutti insieme
alle prime frizzi wang hao che sono tre
però che non sia mai esistita così tanto
una persona suo gioco come ultimo
siccome manca il nero che già sul nero
tra l'altro liquirizia dolce e quella
negativa è kakà di pecore no puzzetta
selvaggia e ultima ma è l'ultima è
l'ultimo 321 via anche la mia questa fa
veramente allora mi sa che popolare
liquirizia dolce che come non mi faceva
compensare una per cambiare e prendi la
ma non so stessi che penso che trova già
basta mangiare caramelle ai ragazzi e
che possiamo concludere qui bravi per sé
per aver partecipato anche se io non ho
perso una volta ma perché lo sapevo dire
che possiamo passare a farvi risponde
dopo questa incredibile avventura la
prima domanda ragazzi arriva da alex guy
la febbre a 37 o a 56 sempre lo stesso
quando fai video quando lo faccio io sì
però vi posso assicurare caro che quando
non faccio i video e cioè la febbre a 37
o anche 36 e mezzo che per me è febbre
sono tipo uno zombie che si trascinano
sul pavimento quindi c'erano sottoposti
però concern veri uomini sanno come
affrontare fa viva il tuo gatto di
peluche e un fai da te oppure lei ha
acquistato ma mi prendi gatto
no no il gatto adesso colori sapevo lo
sapevi come si chiamava magari perfetto
arrivato anche i miei sta cosa regala
comunque ragazzi cat mario che sarebbe
il gatto di peluche
in realtà è un fai da te ma non l'ho
fatto io perché se avessi fatto io
sarebbe uscita da fatto una mia fan
quando avevo tipo forse 10.000 iscritti
quindi questo qua era più e più vecchio
di me ma de silvestri perché non fai un
video con una femme con una femmina
ce n'è anche con una donna ragazzi
abbiamo femmina ti vergogni in questo
preciso momento con degli ospiti così
credi che meglio di far video con una
fetta poi tu sei una femmina
tecnicamente parlando come ha reagito a
cui serve per te proprio come rogito tua
mare mare mare nel senso di marion io
però va bene come reagito tua madre al
tatuaggio di lo turba ma rispondeva
ibamba risponde dai regi maggio è
bellissimo io l'ho trovato stupendo
dunque ho reagito bellissima chi ce l'ha
la mamma così primi allunghi quel 51
sono vere le cose brutte che dicono su
di te non so che cosa dicono su di me ma
qualsiasi cosa sia
no in realtà io sono molto molto peggio
dai ragazzi conclude prima di concludere
lo farà fare domanda perché sennò nomi
ce lo sapete è la fai domanda di oggi
fatto inaf e domanda che mai chiamato a
fare che non ho fatto un caso l'ho mai
fatto una domanda non mai chiesto niente
facciamo una domanda propri j
a che età hai perso i capelli non mi
ricordo non mi sto preoccupando lega
l'età in cui li hai persi tu potrai
perderli anch'io però è un dettaglio
prima di concludere ragazzi volevo dirvi
una cosa perché riguardo al film che è
praticamente già in terapia è diventato
partner di carrefour che sarebbe aveva
fare la spesa bureau due privati ragazzi
con lo scontrino se andate sul sito
questo che vi lascio in descrizione
potete giocare al concorso embra specie
di contest organizzato appunto da
carrefour con i prodotti a loro marchio
potete vincere i biglietti per il film
una maglietta con la mia bella faccia la
mia bella face la partecipazione
all'anteprima del film e infine una
giornata e mia compagnia nel senso che è
una specie di raduno un po più live at
dove possiamo giocare a cose divertenti
insieme
ci andate a fare la spesa a carico si va
avanti sarà un'iniziativa uscita
rispetto la usa vuoi finire finisci
ficili inizialmente riuscirà ad esso
finiscila ai video mi è piaciuto farlo
lei deve farlo né e quindi ragazzi se il
video vi è piaciuto lasciate un commento
o un mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come lo divido tra ton
descrizione dei farebbe benissimo così
anche anche la pagina anche alla pagina
di facebook anche alla pagina difesa
anche alla faglia dai la pagina e anche
la pagina di facebook e lasciate un
commento come in ogni disegno pensa
anche alla pagina di facebook che
trovate in descrizione come in ogni
video se non siete ancora iscritti
iscrivetevi e noi ci rivediamo al
prossimo video blog bella a tutti i
ragazzi mariani allora la nostra vista
del telecomando dall'altra parte punta
su hi fi kato veramente no tipica
veramente